new hardware for the ps5 could be
announced soon and xbox is having some
controller troubles
sony reportedly has more hardware in
development as it's claimed that new
headsets and gaming monitors will be
revealed in the coming weeks the gear is
said to be part of the new enzone line
and will feature three new headsets
designed to cater to various price
points which is good because your boy
ain't made of money the enzone h3 is the
entry-level wired headset the endzone h7
is wireless and has a long lasting
battery life and the enzone h9 is the
premium offering that has noise
cancelling features according to a new
report from exputer all three headsets
will include 360 spatial audio for
gaming and are all discord certified the
two gaming monitors in the report are
said to be made specifically for the
playstation 5 and will include auto hdr
tone mapping black equalizer viewfinders
fps readings and auto genre picture mode
as part of a game assist feature package
exact series names and classifications
haven't been revealed just yet but at
least one of these monitors will provide
a 4k at 144 hertz at display hdr 600
image quality while the other is capable
of full hd at
240 hertz at display hdr 400. so how
much are these new headsets and monitors
gonna cost leave your guesses in the
comments below sony is also rumored to
be working on a pro version of the ps5
dual sense controller which will be
similar to microsoft's elite series xbox
controller and will have removable
analog sticks trigger stops and rear
paddle triggers and speaking of xbox
microsoft has now confirmed that there
is a shortage of xbox controllers the
company spoke with vgc and confirmed
that supply disruptions are currently
affecting stock with a large number of
big retailers completely sold out users
on reset era recently shared their
inability to acquire new xbox
controllers across europe and if there
were any it was in very limited supply
or through scalpers as pointed out by
vgc amazon uk is one of the few
retailers where you can currently
purchase a first party wireless xbox
controller for the recommended retail
price but third-party sellers are
charging almost double with listing
prices starting at
115 dollars at the time of this
recording it doesn't appear that there's
any stock issues in the us with the
microsoft store and best buy still
selling controllers though as pointed
out by vgc amazon us and gamestop are
only selling pre-owned controllers
meaning there might be some stock issues
in some places now switching gears from
hardware to software call of duty has
seen a lot of major hollywood
collaborations over the last few years
including horror movie icons like billy
the puppet and leatherface and most
recently the godzilla in king kong
monsterverse crossover for vanguard and
warzone now it seems the terminator
could be popping up for call of duty
season 4. the call of duty twitter
account shared a new promo teaser for
season 4 which says quote looks like
some mercenary scored an unusual hall
some precious metals shine brighter in
the darkness who can identify the tweet
includes an image of gold bars which
fits the mercenaries of fortune themed
for season 4. however one bar isn't gold
and as charlie intel pointed out
increasing the exposure on the image
will reveal the word skynet on the lone
silver bar mentions of skynet the ai
system that served up the apocalypse in
the popular sci-fi franchise likely
means call of duty will receive some
sort of terminator operator bundle for
vanguard and warzone according to
charlie intel there will actually be two
one with the t800 and one with the t1000
are you excited for terminator and call
of duty or do you really want call of
duty to team up with some more
current characters let me know in the
comments below and i'll see you tomorrow